foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
journalist and author Ian Dunt and the
telegraph's chief political
correspondent Camilla Turner very good
evening to you both they'll be with us
set from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages well now according to the
financial times the war in Ukraine could
be about to enter a new phase it says as
Moscow Lutz at using aircraft and
helicopters
the front of the Daily Express says that
British Army troops insist that they can
stand up to President Vladimir Putin if
Russia attacks a NATO Ally
the Metro reports that Cheshire police
are investigating whether the murder of
16 year old Brianna Jai was a hate crime
as she was transgender
the sun carries a photograph of what it
says is evidence in the case of the
missing mother of two Nicola bully
the eye says there's a postcode Lottery
when it comes to the supply of hormone
replacement therapy drugs with women in
poorer areas far less likely to be able
to get hold of them
and the star offers a light-hearted take
on remarks from a former senior RAF
officer who has insisted that the
objects such as the recent Chinese spy
balloons should not be shot down until
officials can be sure what is inside
them
and uh just a reminder that by scanning
the QR code on the screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers so while you
watch us discussing them and as I say
we're joined tonight by Ian Dunt and
Camilla Turner of course so let's uh
very good evening to you again let's uh
dive straight in then and I want to
start with the financial times quite a
few uh interesting stories on the front
of that and we'll pick out this one
concerning these public sector ways
disputes which have been going on and on
it seems and the Ft asking will sunac
back date key workers pay which would be
a way I suppose of um increasing the
current pay offer Camilla do you think
that might be a solution
um yes this is quite an interesting
suggestion the financial times are
talking about saying this is something
under discussion
um essentially making the the pay award
for for the year ahead which will start
in April but then back dating it to the
start of the year as a way to try and
see off these Stripes once and for all
because of course the government's been
in a complete deadlock with unions
lasting the past few months meaning
we've had rolling public sector strikes
um and there's no end point in sight at
the moment with the different unions
um asking for inflation busting pay
Rises the government trying to hold farm
and they have essentially managed to
sort of stand their ground and wait it
out so the conversation we're now
nearing um April so the conversation
will now be all moving towards next
year's pay Awards whereas the unions
were trying to talk about last year's
pair Awards
um but really for the government it's
not a good look to have these strikes
going on and they're going to need to
find a solution at some point
um and this could be um a potential
waiter to break the deadlock of course
we've got a budget coming up and we know
the views of the treasury on how much
money is available I mean I mean Steve
Barkley the health secretary suggested
this about a month ago or so didn't he
and it did it didn't seem to catch on
then
yeah that's right it was about 10th of
January uh there were briefings to the
Press I think to be independent and to
the guardian at the time sort of stating
that this is a way that we can do it the
union reaction was quite interesting and
it was basically to say well look if
it's a small pay rise the fact that he's
back dated it won't make any difference
if it's a larger pay rise in fact these
back they said it might make some
difference and you get the impression
that Barclay thought it might make some
kind of difference which raises the
question as to what we've gone through
another month of this stuff without any
movement on this and still basically
being presented with stories that are
exactly the same as the ones that we
were looking at a month ago and that
speaks to the bigger problem the
government has which is that it has now
presided over this going on for month
after month after month now if it ends
now at any moment that they come up with
a solution for it the question is going
to be why on Earth did you just come up
with this earlier and save us all an
awful lot of bother and that eventually
ultimately whichever way this goes is
how it's going to play out and also
thinking it through Camilla is it also a
way of trying to Shore up the Union's
confidence in these pay review bodies
because we've also been hearing over the
last few months haven't we that said
well we don't uh we don't trust them we
don't believe them it's you the
government that pulls the strings so
let's talk direct to you
uh yes I think that's right there's been
a huge row going on about these peer
review bodies with the government trying
to say oh well it's not up to us it's up
to these independent pay-per-view bodies
and all we can do is put in our evidence
and see what they say and then you've
had a situation where unions are saying
well we don't really have confidence in
these um processes we're just going to
boycott them and pull out of it all
together so the the things are sort of
really deteriorating and I think some
kind of breakthrough that restores
confidence in these pay review bodies
and also ideally leads to a breakthrough
in the discussions and and gets the
strikes called off is really at this
stage something the government is
probably looking to do having tried to
stand their ground and wait it out and
see if the strikes go away clearly
that's not happening
um and there is still you know at least
some public support particularly for NHS
workers on strike
um a lot of people feeling the pinch
with the cost of living and thinking
well would it be the worst thing to give
these people a pay rise yeah quite a lot
of this dovetails or has relevance to
some of those labor market numbers we
got out today I want to bring in the
Metro which as I say is a related number
of days lost to strikes the highest
since 1989 so in we haven't quite
reached 1970s levels yet uh many many
parallels though of course
well that was too far right so I mean
when you have the deflationary sort of
crisis in the 70s yes you had militant
trade unions far more militant than what
we're seeing today you also had
I mean really OPEC in the oil crisis I
mean when the price of oil spiked the
price of everything just goes up with it
because it is the mechanism by which you
get products from one place to another
of course you have the kind of failure
of the Keynesian system that we've been
using up until then it was it was a sort
of Confluence of factors oil was the
most important and I think that kind of
muscle memory in the government and in
the treasury in particular is part of
the reason they've been so stubborn over
this issue now just thinking like well
look if we'll start unleashing pay Rises
we start stimulating demand we get
inflation going even higher but the
situations
are broadly similar but they're not
exactly comparable and probably a bit
more of that should have been taken into
account a little bit earlier in this
process yeah as I say um it's 1989 we've
reached at the moment and and Camille I
mean what's your assessment have you
touched on it there of how much damage
it's all doing to the government just
also on the Metro there is some lots of
students and indeed their parents and
carers know uh 70 000 University staff
now joined the rally they've been taking
action um for for some time now how
damaging is it for for the government
that you know it just seems to feed into
the broken Britain narrative
absolutely the longer these strikes
continue that the worse a look it is for
a government if you've got a situation
where people can't get a doctor's
appointment they worry about what's
going to happen if they're um elderly
relative Falls over will they um get the
care they need all the ambulance show up
um you know people sort of getting used
to just not not being able to rely on
trains coming on time
um schools having to close University
lecturers but the post's not working
almost every aspect of our public
services are just quite far below far at
the moment and that's
um not something that um really goes
down well for voters it's one of the
factors um that Tori MP cite as as one
of the reasons why their conservatives
are really trailing in the polls at the
moment so it's quite important for the
government to sort this out particularly
as we're coming into the local elections
um which is the first sort of actual
electoral test for issue like it's one
thing to be trading in the polls but
does that translate into the way people
actually vote so I think that is now
some urgency among government ministers
to really try and sort out these strikes
um just because it's then one less thing
for people to hold against them I want
to get on now to the situation in
Ukraine and much to discuss surrounding
that's that but this on the front of the
Daily Express is interesting Ian it's um
a repost from senior defense Chiefs as
the express terms then to this some
reports that came from Germany weren't
they that um NATO did not want Britain
to assume control to provide the high
Readiness Force that's 5 000 troops that
would lead any response should Russia
for instance attack a NATO Ally they
apparently according to German media
claimed that NATO had asked Germany to
continue playing that role um this
report saying well the British army is
ready incapable
yeah I mean which it is I mean first of
all this is not going to happen I mean
Russia has I know it's dangerous to make
predictions when it comes to basically a
lunatic like Putin but nevertheless
Russia has its hands full and can't
really seem to make any sustained
progress in Ukraine as it is the chances
of it opening up another front against
another country and having to trigger a
NATO response a very very unlikely
indeed that did happen I mean you know
what one of the things that Britain has
retained in its capabilities and its
status is the ability for military
action and it would be able to stand up
especially in Alliance with some of the
most powerful countries on Earth so this
doesn't seem really to stack up and it's
again that sort of presentation of just
this this sort of quiver that we've had
over the winter in the western alliance
against Russia that you saw I think with
the sort of Tanks debate over the last
couple of months of just some slight
fractures some slight acrimony in the
western response that frankly at the
moment just isn't particularly helpful
what do you make of it Camilla Britton
is is ready to lead that high Readiness
Force but also as we take in the
financial times
well Russia masses aircraft within
striking range of Ukraine targets the
West warns well one would have imagined
that they've already been doing that but
they've got even more aircraft
helicopters fighter jets throwing into
the water support it's stuttering land
offensive this all then leads into does
it not whether the West will supply its
fighter jets to the ukrainians
um yes that's right and of course this
was
um president zelenski's big plea to the
West when he did his Whistle Stop tour
of um London and other European
um locations last week
um he was really
um calling out on Western allies to say
please provide um Ukraine with fighter
jets
um and this financial time story is
really just showing how much Russia's
ramping up for this um latest offensive
that we've has been talked about for
weeks um and has you know sort of as the
article says the next phase of the war
um so we can see
um on the one hand you've got Russia
ramping up its um response and on the
other hand Western allies still really
just questioning over what their
response is going to be the article
talks about
um uh you know the rapid need for
anti-aircraft defense capabilities but
as well as that of course you've got
zelenski's cause for greater fighter
jets from the West this at the moment is
something
um Western countries are hesitating on
um and there are also questions around
the capabilities of the West how how
many of these do they have how quickly
can they get over to Ukraine so all
sorts of questions there
um and and really um running out of time
probably before Ukraine needs to have
answers on these questions okay we're
going to take a a short break now you
are of course staying with us coming up
as Sarah everard's Kira admits
additional crimes we'll be discussing
what more police forces can do to try to
improve their safeguarding procedures
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview with
me now Ian Dunn and Camilla Turner well
let's have a look at this I mean it's
just so disturbing it's inside the metro
police officers face misconduct claims
on cousins probes now this comes after
he admitted three counts of indecent
exposure one of which took place much
reported in a McDonald's restaurant four
days before he abducted raped and killed
Sarah everard and that of course is
going to be subject we know Ian that
there's an independent inquiry taking
place into whether opportunities were
missed
yeah and I mean it's
you know you don't want to preempt it
but it's really very difficult to see
how the answer to that could be no given
what we're reading right now you know I
mean there is now an investigation into
gross misconduct of at least one officer
in the Met into misconduct for an
officer in the Kent Police about the
manner in which those incidents were
investigated being non-professional in
the manner in which they approached them
failing to follow them up
and I mean that can possibly be because
we treat flashing as this kind of grab
grubby form of antisocial Behavior the
the joke you know that when you're from
the 70s and the 80s
instead of the start of a process
by which someone commits very very
serious sexual and violent offenses
um and it could be and it certainly is
because the police are especially the
man completely unable to deal with this
kind of incident because it has that
culture within it because of the Macho
culture within the met that would
naturally not take these kind of
incidents seriously so we'll need to see
more details but at the moment I mean
it's very hard to look at this in
anything like approaching a reasonable
mind and to think that nothing could
have been done stopped from happening
because by virtue of what we're reading
it clearly could have been yeah I mean
and indeed as you say not to preempt the
inquiry but you know some of the main
questions being given just uh how alert
the restaurant staff were they they had
the number they had the CCTV
um the the fact that he was a police
officer was apparently not discovered
yeah I mean at least one of the
incidents that was not discovered and
the others we had this I mean it's quite
vague the stuff that's being described
at the moment of this sort of
unprofessional behavior particularly
from the Met officer in question which
again we can only come to our own
conclusions as to the kind of thing that
that might entail at the moment but we
can sort of imagine what they might be
so we'll be following the details with
interest but at the moment you know it
does seem to be stacking up a narrative
that we now know very very well indeed
about a vision of the met that just
needs proper route and Branch reform if
it is to maintain the confidence of
women uh and just a quick thought on on
that Camilla I also want to put to you
uh a story in the eye but um yeah the I
mean the clear just stand out questions
that need to be answered about her how
thoroughly the the police investigated
Wayne cousins before he carried out that
appalling crime
yes I think
that this goes far deeper clearly than
the just Wayne cousins it's
um you know the horrific crimes that he
perpetrated and you know the amount that
did for the public and women to sort of
really lose their trust in the police
just because it was so shocking but also
all these missed opportunities and all
these red flags that might have been
raised over time had they been looked
into properly or had the system has been
joined up enough to spot the warning
signs and this McDonald's
um indecent exposure
um
incident coming just a few days before
the the Sarah avarad murder is really
the most shocking
um and I think what all these examples
are showing is just how How deep the
reform of the map needs to be not just
of
um their sort of personnel but also the
checks and balances their systems the
way they record crimes and the way they
look into things because clearly if
quite major red flags are being missed
along the way and then people are going
on to commit far more serious crimes
there's a real problem that and of
course potentially other forces quick
thought on this uh Camilla a very
important story in the eye women face
postcode lottery for HRT Supply the
headline patients living in poor areas
are less likely to be prescribed hormone
replacement therapy amid widespread
shortages
[Music]
shortages across the
Keys being unable to get hold of it or
are now able to prescribe it but what's
really interesting about this story in
the eye is really just showing the
difference between parts of the country
that are more deprived and and the
inaccessibility of HRT in those areas
compared to wealthier areas um nearby so
it's saying that wealthy areas
um spend three times more on menopause
treatments than mgps do in deprived
areas so really showing that depending
on which part of the country you live in
um you're more likely or less likely to
be able to get hold of these drugs
um so quite an important Revelation
there on an issue that's already um we
know is problematic across the country
but with this wealth divide as well as
other geographical divides yeah and uh
interesting thought here in the paper
middle class women are better informed
about symptoms and benefits of HRT and
it's the GPS who need better education
say experts listen we'll discuss that
more in the next hour but we'll leave it
there for the time being thank you both
very much indeed